I could totally pick up any woman in here.
If by that you mean lift her off the ground, then yes, I'll give you that.
I for sure could be a womanizer.
Or you could be.
Someone who just stepped out of a machine called the womanizer.
Okay, you know what? That's it.
Pick anyone in here, If I can get their number, you do the laundry for a month.
If I fail, I'll do it.
Okay. I hate doing laundry, so.
No. Um.
Oh, okay. Right here.
Her. Great.
Great, great.
Let's get rid of my flair.
Whoa. Where did Cam go?
Where is he?
Hey. Oh, my God.
How are you?
Hey. Hey.
Wow. Look at you.
You look fantastic.
Thank you. You. So do.
You. How long has it been?
It feels like forever.
When is the last time we saw each other?
Oh, let's see.
I think it was at Dave's thing.
You know what?
I'm sorry.
I don't know if you've heard.
I was in a terrible car accident, and ever since the coma.
I have a really hard time placing names and faces.
So who are you?
Oh, my God. I am so sorry.
It was just a clever way to try to approach you.
We don't know each other.
I've never been in a coma.
But you so deserved that.
That was the worst pickup ever.
Oh, my God.
That was genius and mean.
Now I know why we're old fake friends.
Oh, can I buy you a drink?
Yeah. I'm Katie.
Cameron. If she were a hot guy, I would never have been that smooth.
It's ironic.
Like the gift of the vagi.
Here we go.
Thank you. Nice to meet you.
You too. Bye bye.
Wham, bam. Thank you, Cam.
Seriously? You got her number?
Sure did. And all my shirts get ironed and their seams should appear straight,
just like their owner.
Katie, you're an amazing woman.
You're smart, you're beautiful.
And how fun is that handbag?
This is going to come as a little bit of a shock.
I'm fairly gay.
I don't know why I said that.
I'm. I'm totally gay.
Just gay.
You're telling me you're gay?
Yeah. Why I was born that way, you know?
So why are you telling me?
I mean, I know you're gay.
It's obvious.
Well, it's not that. It's not that obvious.
Oh, yeah. The way you talk and walk and dress and your theatrical hand gestures.
I do not have theatrical hand gestures.
Okay, maybe I am moderately expressive, but why would you give me your number?
Oh, because I want a gay friend.
Someone I can dish with, give me guy advice, and I can shop with.
Those are totally offensive stereotypes.
We could go see.
Julia Roberts movies.
Together, and she's as nice as she seems on screen.
Shut up. Really?
Is she?
Wait, what? So you were.
Pretending to be straight and hitting on me?
It's just a stupid bar bet.
My boyfriend. Oh, he's here.
Bet me that I couldn't get a beautiful woman's number.
And as a proud gay man, I know it shouldn't matter, but I just wish everyone
could find me attractive.
Oh, now he's going to get to gloat.
And I guess I deserve it.
Hi. Hi.
How was it? How's it going?
Hello.
This is Katie. And it turns out well.
No, actually, it doesn't turn out well because I thought I finally met a nice,
funny guy who is also hot, and now.
He's telling me he's gay.
He's like, the least gay person I have ever met in my entire life.
And I thought he was the one.
And I even. Tell my mom about him.
You better cherish him.
Hello? Wow.
Are you sure you're gay?
No. Cam? Yes.
Yes.
Look, you're going to find somebody because you're an amazing girl, Katie.
You're the whole package.
I just prefer somebody who has one.
Okay
Oh, my God.
That was a lot of girl tongue.
I think I need a drink a doodle doo.